hello friends i'm dave rubin this is the
reuben report direct message it's
november 23rd in the year 2021 we are
live streaming on rumble on youtube on
blaze tv and you can chat live with
other viewers and possibly just possibly
get me a message live during the show if
you go to
reubenreport.locals.com and of course
we've got the ios app and the android
app and all that good stuff
we got three stories for you today we've
got a little uh recap of the media
insanity basically uh post the kyle
rittenhouse verdict
he was on tucker carlson last night for
a one-on-one interview there's a whole
bunch of clips flying around the
internet right now we're going to show
you one or two of them i think you'll
find him to be a pretty thoughtful
young man who is trying to make sense of
a very
nonsensical world tucker did a great job
in the interview then we've got a couple
other clips of mainstream media or
corporate media as it is uh just with
endless disinformation and
misinformation related to kyle related
to the legal system related to america
the whole damn thing so that's story
number one story number two uh jen saki
remember jen saki we haven't heard much
from jen saki lately because she got
covid despite being vaccinated being
vaccinated it's almost as if the
vaccines don't work as promised i don't
want to get banned from the internet
um well she's now saying that joe biden
is going to run in 2024
for what i have no idea but uh we're
gonna tell you about that with some
quotes from jen and then i said to the
guys right before we started i said can
we find the best clip of joe biden
rambling incoherently we put it in the
computer machine over there and there
were thousands and thousands of options
to choose from we got one that we just
watched again it's from about a year ago
but i was laughing so hard i had to use
a tissue to get the tears out of my eyes
so we're going to show that to you and
then finally remember thomas jefferson
one of the great founders of the united
states a man who wrote so many of the
documents that freed so many of us and
that have lived
for 250 years and done a lot of good
work in the world and was just a good
decent man and a man of his time who was
not perfect but you know net good i
would say they just took his statue out
of new york city hall
there was a particular orange man i
can't remember his name if one of you
guys could google it about a year ago
who was saying that oh if you take down
these statues eventually they're going
to come for guys like thomas jefferson
and george washington i don't remember
that orange man's name but here we are
all right let's move on so uh kyle
rittenhouse obviously the big news of
the last couple days is that on friday
he was acquitted of murder acquitted of
all charges the media has just been an
endless meltdown about this it's really
been quite sickening and disgusting but
it was good on one hand because finally
last night we got to hear from kyle
himself he joined tucker carlson for a
one-on-one and i thought this was the
clip that i wanted to show you this is
about
kyle's feelings on being called a white
supremacist
by president joe biden
what did you make of the president
states calling you a white supremacist
mr president if i could say one thing to
you i would urge you to go back and
watch the trial
and understand the facts before you make
a statement
that's not a small thing to be called
that
no it's
it's actual malice defaming my character
for him to say something like that
i mean why do you think and it's not
simply biden who said that
yeah it is malice it is defaming your
character it is not surprising however
uh that joe biden called him a white
supremacist a gajillion blue check media
people have called him a white
supremacist let's just be very very
clear there is zero
there is zero evidence that kyle
rittenhouse is a white supremacist you
may not like some of his actions that
can be debated but there is no evidence
that he wants white people to be treated
better than black people or brown people
or any other people if you watch the
full interview he felt that he was doing
what he could to de-escalate a situation
where the police were not taking care of
property and of citizens in the area and
you may agree with his actions or
disagree with his actions that's fine
but when the president of the united
states calls someone a white supremacist
with absolutely no evidence we got a
real problem on our hand now i should
also remind you that when joe biden
launched his presidential campaign a
couple years ago he said in the video
that he launched you can find it online
that he got in that he didn't want to
get back in because he was vp then he
took a four-year break obviously he did
not want to get into the running until
the events of charlottesville when
basically uh
donald trump said there are very fine
people on both sides and back the
neo-nazis now i have debunked this a
million times as other people have
online donald trump immediately
condemned the neo-nazis and all those
people he said there are very fine
people on both sides of the debate
around whether you should take statues
down which obviously that is true anyway
i mentioned that because biden has a
long history of calling people racists
and white supremacists and nazis and the
rest of it when they clearly are not so
i would highly recommend you watch at
least some of the other clips of kyle
rittenhouse because as you can see he
just comes off as a thoughtful decent
kid there's it's shocking actually he
has very little anger or venom for the
people that did this to him he you know
the anyone that has gone through what
he's gone through in the last year he
talks about the conditions in jail and
everything else could have been broken
or bitter or angry or resentful i mean
or a litany of other things that you
know have all sorts of psychological
problems but he seems okay uh now the
interesting thing is a lot of people are
saying that written house should sue
president biden that this is defamation
of character we have libel and slander
and all these sorts of things this is an
interesting one because look you guys
know my policy on speech right we want
as much free speech as possible you want
people to be able to say whatever they
want you don't want them to be able to
directly call for violence to someone
you can't yell fire in a crowded theater
with the intent of causing mayhem there
are a few things and then we have these
very
very specific uh rules around speech
related to libel and slander
so we have to be careful what we ask for
here like has has joe biden done
unimaginable damage to kyle
rittenhouse's um life absolutely his
reputation absolutely have msnbc
and cnn journalists have they done
unimaginable damage to this kid
absolutely um but once we start going
down that path where you start suing
people for saying bad things about you
it's just a slippery slope i'm not i'm
actually not saying he should do it this
is such an extraordinary case that maybe
he should um but we do have to just be
careful what we ask for there but let's
move on for a second because a lot of
this and i've been saying this for a
couple weeks that one of the reasons i
didn't want to cover the trial the
nitty-gritty of the trial every day is
that people have to live their lives
people have to go about uh you know
doing the best they can in these crazy
times and i think if we all get caught
in every little minutia of the of the
trial it can get it's a little insider
baseball i don't think it's the wisest
use of time so what i've tried to do is
cover the media coverage of this because
right there's a reality that happens in
the courtroom but that reality then goes
through a filter right you got a filter
here msnbc cnn washington post new york
times that filter then changes the
reality for the average person that's
over here just trying to live their life
and know roughly what's going on what is
actually true well cnn and msnbc
particularly i mean msnbc is just it's
just a racist network it is just a
racist network and if you know anyone
that's watching msnbc you you got to
drug them and then reprogram them okay
that that's that's my position on this
um anyway chris cuomo last night on cnn
he purports to be a journalist but he's
just a democrat activist he's a
progressive
uh who you know for a year ran cover for
his brother who is the democrat mayor
governor of new york
uh he often goes on these rants on his
show telling you what he thinks while
he's also pretending to be a journalist
it's very very confusing he had some
thoughts on the written house verdict
and what's going on in the country
now kyle rittenhouse who wants to tell
his story who wants to be understood for
his own words and his own deeds not what
the media likes not what the left likes
not with the right likes sat across from
a man who is known
uh for coloring perception and creating
animus in society the same animus that's
feeding on kyle rittenhouse uh and that
complicates things
and for a 17 year old who says they want
somewhere to protect
a community that their father worked in
that they felt a connection to
he's become everything
that is ugly about the battle between
white and black and right and wrong and
justice and injustice in this country
does that seem like editorializing or
straight up journalism reporting facts
to you now of course he goes after
tucker there because tucker gets ratings
and he really doesn't so he knows if he
talks about tucker maybe tucker will
talk about him and that's how the sort
of media thing the media little circular
lunacy works but i want to repeat that
that quote there to you that he said at
the end about kyle rittenhouse now kyle
was just acquitted on all charges by a
jury of his peers that's how the system
works
what cuomo decided to say was that kyle
rittenhouse has quote become everything
that is ugly about the battle between
white and black and right and wrong and
justice and injustice in this country
you know it's funny we just talked about
libel and slander it's like kyle is all
of those things
he's
the ugly thing between white and black
and justice and injustice
i mean
and right and wrong
well the jury just said that he was
right so what side are you on
cuomo what are what are we really
saying here cuomo uh but it continues of
course at cnn they brought on van jones
and and often people say to me dave you
know when you were more liberal
when you used to consider yourself a
liberal and yes i did write a book
defending liberalism but as you know
liberalism has been kicked in the nuts
and is kind of hunched over in the
corner going help me help me i can't get
up liberalism has a problem right now
but people often say to me dave there
are liberals out there who are decent
there's bill maher they always tell me
about bill maher and they always tell me
about van jones that's the other one
they always tell me about and van jones
is a liberal sort of he's thought of as
sort of this non-woke liberal something
like that who often goes on cnn to tell
he's an opinion guy i suppose so i i
don't deny him his opinion on this uh
what we're going to show you here on cnn
but i'm always told that he's a good
liberal well here's what uh van jones
said about black americans in america
today i think the reason that you have a
lot of shock and anger and frustration
from the black community and from
progressives is there's never been an
african-american kid you think of 400
years of of provocations and bad stuff
that's happened and threats against us
has there been an african-american kid
that walked around with an ar-15 and
shot three people and got held as a hero
ever and it will never happen and so
there's just from the very beginning a
sense that uh there's there too there's
a two-tier system here where we don't
have the right to self-defense in the
same way i don't have a second amendment
right in the same way if dan jones
walked down the street with an ar-15 you
know what you say about me it sure was
nice knowing dan jones because i'm not
gonna have a chance to explain myself
no van jones that's a complete lie if
you were walking down the street and
three white men or black men or asian
men or aliens attacked you and you used
your gun to defend yourself every
single conservative and scary republican
would defend your right to do that the
idea i mean it's a crazy statement i
don't have a second amendment right in
the same way yes you do all men are
created equal if we had a law
that said you as a black man are not
allowed to protect yourself that would
be a problem and i would be on your side
but this is the endless racializing of
absolutely everything
we all everyone knows if there was just
a young black kid who was being attacked
out of nowhere and he did whatever he
had to do with self-defense we would all
be applauding him for it we would all be
uploading for whether he had to beat the
crap out of those kids or shoot those
kids or whatever
it is what they're all trying to do is
take a very
sort of murky situation out of the
written house thing and at the height of
the pandemic and all of the race stuff
and everything was such a mess and we
were watching cities burn down and we
literally literally me dave we moved i
mean i left my house and moved to
another house in the midst of all of
that partly because the protests were
about a half a block from our house and
i knew that people knew where i lived
and i was getting screamed at and a
whole bunch of other stuff i don't even
think i've ever said that publicly
before um so people were freaking out
like oh are the police going to do the
right thing or if i call the police if
i'm under attack if my family is under
attack if someone breaks into my house
if the store down the block is burning
down are the police or the firemen or is
anyone going to show up is anyone in
charge here or is it all being
instigated and pushed by the progressive
mayors and all of the
policy people in these cities i think
you all know the answer to those things
so the idea that van jones doesn't have
the second amendment right of course he
does he also has the first amendment
right which he just used right there so
he has those things just as every other
black person does every latino person
every gay person and every trans person
you can basically say whatever you want
i mentioned some of those exclusions
earlier
and it's dangerous it's actually
dangerous what he's doing because i just
know it i think if you just sit for a
second and think about it just really
think about it if if you found out
tomorrow that that van jones was walking
uh outside of the cnn he wrapped up that
that little appearance right there and
he walked out of the cnn building and
suddenly
four angry
trump supporting red hat noose carrying
you know the all go with all the made-up
stuff that you can come up with and they
attacked van jones out of nowhere and
then he shot them in self-defense every
single conservative would be applauding
it and we all know it so it's very very
dangerous when these people racialize
everything and i don't like it very much
okay
let's move on jen saki you know jen saki
she is the white house press secretary
she is a woman who is completely
incapable of saying anything true and
i'm fairly certain that her prediction
here also will turn out not to be true
she says that old joe confused muddled
pudding for a brain joe biden that he is
going to run again in 2024. we've got a
quote here from the hill
president biden intends to run for
re-election in 2024. white house press
secretary jensachi confirmed on monday
following a flurry of reports on
discussions among democrats about
whether he would follow through on a bid
for a second term that's his intention
saki told reporters confirming reports
that biden has been telling advisors and
staff that he plans to run again in
2024. biden would be 82 at the start of
his second term if re-elected he was
already the oldest individual to be
inaugurated when he was sworn in in
january and his poll numbers have
steadily declined amid dissatisfaction
with the state of the economy and rising
prices in particular okay let's be clear
here joe biden is not running for a
second term i do not believe that joe
biden will even finish this term we are
only ten or so months into term number
one his cognitive abilities have
obviously uh failed faster than they
intended and they clearly knew something
was wrong with him there is a scandal
brewing as i always say the scandal is
the non-scandal the fact that not
everyone's talking about this at all
times that is the scandal the way they
can basically take your eye off
something that you really can see that
is the scandal around joe biden on top
of the fact that the presidency has been
an abject disaster no matter what they
tell you oh they're telling you how
great the economy is gas prices parts of
la over five dollars a gallon we know
about the supply chain stuff let's not
even talk about afghanistan anymore like
we all know all the stuff we know all
that i do not believe he will run again
obviously it's just nonsense but that's
just sort of political posturing and
media lap dog sort of bs but as i said
at the top of the show
when i saw the story i said why don't we
find a clip of joe biden having one of
his joe biden moments and i think we
just found this is about a two-minute
clip you may remember this i believe
this is the same speech
in which biden referenced corn pop
okay i think it's the same exact speech
as corn pop but this is a different part
a lesser known part of the corn pop
speech
uh here's joe biden just if you don't
laugh during this no no not if you don't
laugh i laughed hysterically again
that's why i have the tissues here i was
laughing hysterically my guys were
laughing hysterically i just want you to
really listen to this
and
you tell me if this makes any sense what
this man said in front of these people
for two minutes here we go i learned a
lot
and i learned that uh
it makes a difference this was the
diving board area
and i was one of the guards
and there weren't allowed through the
three meter board and you fell off
sideways you landed on the damn the darn
cement over there
and corn pop was a bad dude
and he ran a bunch of bad boys
and i did yeah he and back in those days
the shot things have changed one of the
things you had to use if you used pomade
in your hair you had to wear a bathing
cap
and so he was up on the board one list
of me i said hey esther you
off the board i'll come up and drag you
off
well he came off
and he said i'll meet you outside my car
this was mostly these were all public
housing behind it
my car there was a gate out here i
parked my car outside the gate
and i he said i'll be waiting for you he
was waiting for three guys in straight
razors
not a joke
there was a guy named bill wright mouse
the only white guy and he did all the
pools he was the mechanic
and i said what am i going to do he said
come down here in the basement where
mechanics where where all the pool
filter is you know the chain used to be
a chain that went across the deep end
and he cut off a six foot length of
chain he folded up he said you walk out
with that chain
and you walk to the car and say you may
cut me man but i'm gonna wrap this chain
around your head
i said you're kidding me
he said no if you don't don't come back
and he was right
so i walked out with the chain
and i walked up to my car
and they had those days used to remember
the straight razors bang them on the
curb get them rusty put them in a rain
barrel get them rusty
and i looked at them but i was smart
then i said first of all i said when i
tell you get off the board you get off
the board and i'll kick you out again
but i shouldn't have called you esther
williams i apologize for that
i apologize but i know that apology is
going to work he said you apologize to
me i said i apologize for that not for
throwing you out but i apologize for
what i said
he said okay close the straight razor my
heart began to beat again
there are people
who believe that that man is running the
united states of america
and i'd like to have what they're having
because it must be
beautiful to live in that world what the
high hell is he talking about what is
going on there i do stand corrected that
actually was the corn pop clip when we
showed it uh right before the show we we
missed those first 10 seconds that was
the corn pie i don't know who corn pop
is i don't know who mouse is the rusty
chains and the guy and the pomade with
the what is he talking about and the
best part of that
is go watch it again later
he rambles for two minutes nobody in
their right mind please if you're if
you're watching right now and you're in
the live chat uh please someone tell me
what that all meant like sum it up for
me can someone sum it up for me but the
best part of all that is he rambles
completely incoherently in this in a
deranged way for two minutes and then
when he gets to whatever the punch line
is which i'm still unclear what it was
everyone laughs says oh yes well of
course with the chains and the mouse and
corn pop and the
yeah he's going to be president in 2024
they're all just liars they're such
freaking liars
but joe's got problems and joe believe
it or not he's even got problems
here in crazy los angeles this is video
from downtown los angeles today people
are protesting vaccine mandates and they
don't like joe
[Applause]
i just want to be very clear here
brandon has a much much better chance of
running in 2024 than joe biden like much
better chance uh on locals kimbo says
joe can't run he can barely walk
touche good point
and uh bazooka joe says it will be a
full weekend at bernie's if brandon runs
in 2024 i'm pretty sure we're at weekend
at bernie's level already okay let's
move on to the third story uh look you
guys all know my feelings about thomas
jefferson i talk about him often he is
my favorite founder if you have not seen
it a couple years ago we did a
president's week series of episodes
where i did a full hour uh on thomas
jefferson uh he lived extraordinary life
he was writing the documents that were
freeing the slaves in the midst of
writing the documents that were freeing
us
from britain i mean he he did so many
things and he was an inventor and
extraordinary extraordinary person i've
been to his his home down in monticello
in uh in virginia a couple times i
highly recommend you go there and they
give a fantastic tour there well
surprise surprise the woke cultists now
want him taken down wherever he might be
and they are succeeding in places such
as the new york city council uh we've
got some info from the new york post
here thomas jefferson is no longer in
the room where it happens art handlers
packed up an 884
pound statue of jefferson in a wooden
crate monday after a mayoral commission
voted to banish the likeness of the
nation's third president from new york
city hall where it resided for nearly
two centuries because he owns slaves the
1833 statue will be on long-term loan to
the new york historical society which
plans to have jefferson's model survive
in its lobby and reading room terry
butler the executive director of the
public design commission that voted to
banish the statue at first tried to
block the press from witnessing its
removal butler relented after members of
the mayor's office and city council
intervened and we've actually got some
video of the statue being removed after
187 years
all right so almost 200 years that thing
was there 187 to be specific um do you
feel the tolerance do you feel we're
becoming less racist do you feel we're
becoming more diverse and more open and
more thoughtful as a society as we burn
down our history do you sense that or
could this be about something else could
this be about destroying all of the good
past of the united states so that they
can usher in their woke crypto
fascist marxist lunacy do you think
maybe that's closer to what it's about
i've often talked about the the
conflicting history of thomas jefferson
who is just a man of his time much like
we are all just men of our time right
like i love eating a steak is it likely
or possible that in 30 years from now
they will look back on us with our
instagrams of those beautiful juicy
tomahawks that i smoke and go my god he
was evil and then they're gonna have to
take down the giant bust of me wherever
it might be where do you think they
would put a bust of me
somewhere back in the back of my office
will they take down my office yes um
we are all men of our time we're all
imperfect we in most cases try to do the
best we can and we often fail at that uh
thomas jefferson as i said he was
writing the laws to free the slaves he
was conflicted about slavery he felt
that it couldn't just you couldn't just
rip the band-aid off he wasn't a pure
abolitionist in that way but he was he
was trying to make it happen he we know
he had relations with at least one of
his slaves like these are all very
complex things you can also go to george
washington's home in dc and you they
talk about during the tour they talk
about how when when washington died
that he freed his half of his slaves in
his will but martha kept hers does that
mean we should
take down every washington statue i mean
i don't want to give these people any
ideas
but
the idea that these people were somehow
racist and backwards and now 200 plus
years later we're just so great and
we're just closing the loophole on all
their evil crap so that we can be good
and tolerant and diverse going forward
it's just
it's a bill of goods that they're
selling you that is that is
faulty
it is broken and there will be no
warranty on it once we say goodbye to
our history there will be no getting it
back they will usher in something that
will be far
far worse if you thought that george
washington and thomas jefferson were bad
guys wait till you are under the rule of
ilhan omar and aoc and all of their
friends and you will find out the true
meaning of racism and intolerance
because it wasn't those guys it really
wasn't and you should particularly
remember that on a week like this
because because it is thanksgiving of
course and i hope that you guys will be
taking a little time off the news and
spending time with family and friends
and eating great food and drinking good
wine and all of that good stuff uh if
you haven't seen it yet my full
interview with melanie kirkpatrick who
is a scholar when it comes to
thanksgiving you can learn all sorts of
stuff about the founding of thanksgiving
and why we eat certain foods and all
sorts of traditions that people have all
over the world actually because in some
ways it's not just an american holiday
anymore because of the way people have
traveled that is up right now on the
youtube and if you'd like to play along
if you'd like to share recipes if you'd
like to see what we're eating our
cooking begins today you can join us at
reubenreport.org
and uh
well i teased it the other day but
there's some good things coming give me
a couple weeks we got something cooking
and i'm not talking about the turkey
some things are cooking people here i'll
send you a message i'm going to try to
send i haven't done this in a while i'm
going to send you a person watching this
right now i'm going to try to send you a
message so that you will
know what i'm talking about and then
when i announce it in a couple weeks it
will be lodged firmly in your brain here
we go
yeah that's right
that's right all right have a good one